this is so gorgeous did you see this
Temple thing the ripping off music he's
uh the Muse thing is the gift that keeps
on giving okay so as we all know world
famous musician Temple and Eliza
Bluestein
and quartering blocker yeah that too
which is hilarious
um says this earlier this year Muse
announced their album well the people
and their ad for their song is like a
live action remake of our song
[Laughter]
you need to have the disclaimer on the
bottom of the screen from the South Park
Mormon episode this is what Tim Poole
actually believes
he leaves this like look I know we call
him a grifter all the time and he is
he's very full of [__] he has no
Integrity whatsoever but I want to make
it very clear
he believes this
how
which is the funniest thing this is this
is up there with I still think it's not
as good as the you know I realize I'm
probably never gonna have a family and
that's not my fault
well that one that one or that one's a
good one it's my favorite simple moment
that that was a good one or the I don't
get it why don't these college girls
just drop out of college and lose their
scholarship to make a point I mean come
on why are you kids just not play sports
uh
[Laughter]
quit your job five years out of
retirement yeah exactly that's a good
point uh I worked for Disney did you
that sounds great that's cool I know a
lot of [__] losers that work for
Disney here we go I got something I just
did something for you merch I did it on
the Fly
but I just here we go I'm putting it on
the video right now
okay all right
Lou Ferrigno in the chat those food
buckets have scrambled eggs Who's
Laughing Now
foreign
that's one of those slow Burns and you
laughed at him
yeah well I don't think it has it has uh
real eggs in it it's probably got that
you know
powdered [__] yeah let me fix this
texting because I just oh I just uh all
right there you go boom okay
all right here you go merge through
duration of this video
just so you know
this will be under the video so so wow
there we go okay there you go what song
was it which song okay listen I don't
know there were so many bangers have you
heard of a little song called uprising
foreign
the one that has 250 million views on
YouTube not not his The Muse song that
he claims is Uprising oh
okay well like I don't have any respect
for them either so it just sounds like a
gate do we have the new Muse video and
do we have the old Tim pool video yeah
let's see see if we can pull those up
together let's see what he says here
news announced their album well the
people and their ad for their song is
like a live action remake of Our Song
and it was just like the same name the
same color scheme the same themes the
same uh Illusions people with hoodies on
pulling down the statue with an orange
sky so what you're but you're basically
kind of slowly revealing is that your
derivative
he doesn't he he doesn't understand
color grading bro he didn't [__] bro
he got he's he stole our [__] dude it's
called After Effects Tim and you [__]
[__] bro hit the sink bro he was using
the same kind of cameras he had the
white balance set up the same there were
people with hoodies in his music video
wait what I mean come on dude it's
pretty obvious they were ripping me off
it's pretty obvious Muse has my studio
miked and throwing ropes even the timing
of how they threw the ropes because we
did it damn you know what Tim then you
should sue them
they had ropes
I think Tim should sue Muse then if he
really believes this who is he his
brother
looks like we showed the future in the
past they did too
and then we were talking about how like
we were working on this album with a
bunch of songs and we do and um I think
ultimately we decided it was it was we
just want to do our thing because we
were talking okay we're gonna be
releasing our album will of the people
on the same time they are because their
album's coming out on Friday and our
song is being released but we just
there's a lot of things that came into
play one
I don't care to be involved in any kind
of whatever dispute it is they're trying
to do but not
what
he's [__] insane
he's [__] in the amount of people
that go I liked him poor it's disturbing
and IRL I'm sure you've heard people say
that right like IRL I've heard people
say you know just in casual conversation
like I actually like that Tim pool guy
and then I go I I don't have time it's a
litmus test I'll be like I can't but to
my thing is like I don't have time to
explain what I just go all right man
like I'm not gonna I don't I don't have
time to explain to you why he's terrible
I stopped being friends with people if
they say that because our witness test
for your intelligence yeah you search
for our song you get Muse like I feel
like that was intentional like that's
their their YouTube no don't hear me out
YouTube
is colluding
Tim with Muse
Tim
to keep Tim pulled down
dude this is the equivalent of like that
crazy person who's like I was watching
Home Improvement and I swear through the
television Pamela Anderson said marry me
come find me it's important pools
[__] Quentin Tarantino's character
From Dusk Till Dawn yes you want to eat
my [__] like what huh all right so
anyway so anyway Jody anyway Jody Foster
told me to kill Ronald Reagan I guess
what I'm trying to say yes
he really believes this yeah I sent you
links to both the videos that he's
talking thank you well I will play them
right after this or a major label band
they know that we had gotten several
million hits and there's a free ride
coming you know
why would Muse need a free ride do you
know who Muse is no Muse has been riding
Tim pool's coattails for years I gotta
back them up on this
Muse's video just just to have an
example okay
just well I just searched the Muse okay
they're not their number one video has
250 million views all right the LA them
playing live this song has three million
views on its own what was the name of
Temple stupid song
well I do have the link to it oh yeah
you're right cool call
also Tim if you make an album and you
don't tour then it's just a stupid gay
vanity project
if you really love music so much go on
tour if you're so good if there's so
many people that if you're so confident
in your numbers in your music career go
on tour
so this is the all the people he hired
to be on his album are on tour with that
actual bands oh oh it's the drummer back
with like anybody or I'm sure he's with
somebody who's actually doing something
in the music yeah you know how you find
out where that with that without those
kind of drummers are any band who just
lost a drummer is he gonna be driving
for Foo Fighters soon because Taylor
Hawkins died it's one of those like you
know whenever somebody dies in a rock
band it's like oh Zach Wild's gonna
replace him yes every band in every band
Zach Wilder replace him
you guys here they're doing a Hall and
Oates tour [__] Zack Wild's supposed
to replace oats
so Temple temples video has 2.4 million
views it was put up two years ago will
of the people okay it's two years old
huh yeah
Muse's video put up eight months ago has
4.2 million views yeah you're right they
need you you're right they do so this is
but it was like a slingshot effect this
is this is this this is you should play
the temple one wait the temple one first
okay yeah play the temple one okay this
is Temple's will of the people you guys
don't get it Muse only got all those
hits because people were looking for
Tims
they were looking for this hot fire
huh yeah generic gears on a screen
dad Rock
that's what it sounds like it sounds
like the menu music and rock band it's
like a Chinese rock band it sounds like
a Daughtry B-side
oh
ah he's so bad
[Music]
boy I am alive
morning
it's good
yeah man it is should we compare it so
bad this is Muse yeah this is what this
is how Muse copied him let's see me is
he had wind in his video there was wind
noise
if anything they ripped off The
Beautiful People yeah this feels like a
Marilyn Manson ripoff and they're doing
it on purpose I think is the point
[Music]
all right I will say this this sucks
yeah it's pretty gay but it's
everything's made better yeah because
it's Muse yeah at least it's original
dog [__] yeah thank you
[Music]
how is this like this video
I think he's saying that because
about rebellion man
and then and this is the hooded people
so and then his video which is
[Applause]
no not even slightly
and I'm not saying that because I
dislike Temple because it's not like I
like Muse the music's ripping them off
I'd say it but it's just absurd but it's
it's like it's exactly what what's going
to be on the bottom of the screen again
Tim you sound like Temple actually
believes this Tim you sound like the
shitty band from The Sopranos visiting
day yeah oh my God you're right that's
what he sounds like
oh my god I've recorded in Denmark
dude [__] okay Tim I got here's I got
a hot take for you Tim all right I'm
sorry
hey
authoritarianism existed before you
wrote that shitty [__] song you
stupid [__] that's a really good
point do you think armed Rebellion you
invented that with your shitty music
video
look at him look look behind him look
behind him it's like the trophy case
from Predator two what do you have a
[__] musket and a samurai sword you
[__] weirdo black powder pistol yeah
that's that's gonna come in handy uh I
just I just sent you a great [__]
link boys all right this this shows
Matthew Bellamy actually being
rebellious in the face is the media
Giants
it's time stamped all right so this was
this was [__] Muse they went on some
like some Daytime television show or
something
and you guys don't use
the music the the producer came up to
them and specifically said
do not curse
okay
[Music]
this is live
okay okay that's you know what I like
them I'm on music side now I'm a mini a
million music side that is hilarious
[__] [__] [__] what was that it
just was he just [__] up and just
didn't care he's drunk and they told him
not to curse no they he no they show up
to this [__] this live performance
and like Muse never curses so the
producer going up to him and going all
right man out guys okay this is really
funny okay so you don't listen to our
music at all in any way shape [__] you
[__] you
[Music]
[Laughter]
Matt Bellamy uh distracts himself as a
left-leaning Libertarian and expressed
interest previously in the theory that
the 911 attacks were an inside job
yeah
yeah but you have to understand
something in like the new political
sphere a left-lean Libertarian is a
fascist to them now you have to
understand that yeah much
[Music]
they did the banjo player for Mumford
and Sons because he was Republican like
they literally kicked him out of the he
no he quit he was like all right you
know what I'm not gonna apologize
anymore I'm [__] leaving uh Scarface
God Temple's such a [__]
yeah can't argue that hold on we're not
even through this whole video this was
Tim Poole actually believes whatever uh
but you know what we we're gonna do our
own thing and just just steer clear of
stupid drama it's like you know you know
what the Muse Temple things like
remember like Tupac and Biggie beef like
the two greats at the top
were fighting and Nas pretended he was
there remember that I didn't do that
remember when Nas interjected himself he
was like yeah yeah I was three huh look
at us three guys it's like looking in a
freaking mirror look at us who'd believe
it huh not me not me
yeah you're right when the guy's at the
top are battling it out but Tim you made
a video where you're accusing me of
stealing your [__]
and then you're going but I'm not going
to play this game with them I'm not
going to give them what they want I'm
not going to start this I'm not going to
keep their war going they've never
mentioned I don't think they've ever
talked about him have they maybe
we need to get somebody hey Matthew
Bellamy do you know who timpole is who
who
I'm not I thought the song was kind of
crap dude dudes you guys like The
Beautiful People the will of the people
I mean it's just a ripoff of Marilyn man
this is the other Adam Crigler right
is it other Adam Craig yes yeah
answering the song and your color scheme
on your song will of the people it's
crazy it's not just a color scheme oh my
God nobody's ever used [__] orange
and blue color grading before ever ever
hold on give me two seconds right
yeah
our our video starts with an orange sky
and ropes hanging from a statue and then
there's Constantine
so does the way the [__] Iraq war
ended yeah I'm pulling down a Saddam
statue you [__] hack
uh you know my movie they ripped off my
movie like you know in my movies when
you go to Mexico there's like a yellow
film over the entire screen and then
some other guys started doing it
it's like it's mine he was the guy it
was the guy yeah it was all right yeah
and then the next scene changes to the
Statue not being pulled over and then
then the ropes get thrown like we did an
inversion yes you're right because what
Muse who signed a water media was like
what do we do with our next music video
where do we draw inspiration who do we
get you know what there's this young kid
young go hard named Tim Paul who's
taking the podcasting World by fire he's
so busy with his podcast he won't even
notice
on the time thing and and their video is
like I would say it's 85 the exact same
thing okay we just skimmed through and I
could tell you it was 100 certainty
about the exact same thing right it has
one similarity they both suck they both
suck
a link to a collage of movie posters
that are ripping off Temple oh I'm
excited yes yes
oh you're such an [__]
all of these movies are rippington pool
off they're advertising they should all
give to him for advertising damn you
should sue the guys that made the porn
identity
oh you're gonna make me the same with my
[__] ad blocker you son of a [__]
was watching a movie and a half when it
was over there was this thing there's
like these these all these names started
scrolling from the bottom of the screen
to the top of the screen and I did that
first
Sometimes here we go I got it up again
uh Tim pool no
damn Tim
why Disney really is uh stealing your
[__] huh well that's what you get for
leaving them high and dry Tim
you [__] hack
he's such a [__] hack
hey what the [__] was oh that goes
that wasn't good yeah I don't feel I
don't feel any of that and say this
political philosophical space like I
certainly wouldn't ever believe that
people listen to what I say and then
like three to four weeks later put out
you know basically the same video like
they thought and then you guys are all
just indulging him like this is part of
like all these people that enabled him
they're just as bad as him like like Tim
doesn't have any [__] like real
friends in his life like Tim doesn't
have one person to go he's sounding a
[__] [__] stop yeah the last one
that [__] he had got criggler
mm-hmm I just kind of the politics a
year ago I think I looked more than you
the same book like they thought it was
up nuts at that it would be crazy if
that happened they released somebody
said Epic Rap Battles of History Tim
pool versus the quartering that wouldn't
work because it's like it would Echo
promo like a you know they say the same
talking points they release the promo on
my birthday dude I love that Jeremy
sucked his dick after he would throw him
under the box and blocked them
no but even after he blocked him even
after this still sucked his dick even
after yeah Jeremy's a punk [__]
they released it on his birthday hold on
it's the promo on my birthday right they
released it on you know two months ago
yeah so he thinks that it's not only
they ripped it's a personal attack on
him he thinks that Muse is is
engaging in a psychological warfare
against him Temple targeted individuals
Tim
like I remember when CM Punk got served
as papers from WWE like on his wedding
day yeah he was like oh it was petty and
some people were like it couldn't have
been I believe to this day that was
petty yes it's easy to get a wedding
date and [__] a guy over and serving
papers this is insane Tim how do you how
do they even know your birthday yeah
your birthday or like today no I'm
pretty sure they released it on no I'm
sure it's my birthday I upset don't
don't ruin my story I obsess I obsess
about these things it's about me of
course I know oh you saw he released the
for his uh he released the first part of
his little Eliza blue expose like on a
site like an art news article but part
one because he's got a grift of course
it's got to come out in part look up the
will of the people promo it's March 9th
I'm pretty sure June 1st is when the
video went live right promo the promo
I'm pretty sure that was like a copy of
this this is the crazy thing where I'm
like dude there's no way that was an
accident
yep that is crazy so important crazy
it's the opposite operative word there
crazy yeah you sound crazy
Tim you sound just like my ex